I was on vacation recently to a part of
western Sweden called vadym Skoog where
most of my family on my mother's side is
from and where we own a house that we
usually stay in over the summer now in
this community there is a modest but
beautiful church located right next to
the water in a really Dilek landscape
and this church and its history is
interesting for many different reasons
if you're into that sort of thing at
least but primarily for two reasons one
of them is the very location of the
church itself the building that stands
today doesn't day too far back or was
actually built in 1762 and we built or
renovated in 1802 after much of it had
been tragically destroyed in a fire but
preceding this there have been two
previous churches standing at this very
location the oldest of which dates all
the way back to the 13th century making
it one of the oldest in the region now
what's really interesting is that all
these churches are in the vicinity of a
hill or elevation in the landscape and
this hill is known in Swedish as clock :
which translates to something like the
clock hill or the hill of the clock
excavations at this location has found
that this was a kind of graveyard dating
back to the Iron Age in pre-christian
times graves have been found along with
shards of pottery which points to this
conclusion some of these finds have led
to the general assumption that this Hale
used to be some sort of ritual space or
cultic place for pre-christian religious
traditions the fact that the old church
was built at this very specific location
is very interesting from a historical
point of view it seems to be a case of
Christian appropriation of older
traditions in a strategy to more easily
gain converts if one builds the ritual
space the new ritual space of a new
religion in the same location of the old
tradition this avoids dramatic breaks
with the past and makes transition and
conversion much smoother in fact this
was a very common practice by it many of
the Christian missionaries and one that
was largely very successful the
strategy of taking older ideas places
and holidays that was celebrated or
practiced by the people of these new
regions that one was venturing into and
giving these traditions and new
christian clothing another example of
this relates to the Christian holidays
of All Saints Day and All Souls Day
which at least when coming to Western
Europe began to be celebrated on
November 1st and November 2nd at the
exact same time that the old Celtic
Festival Cerwyn was being held possibly
or I should say probably in a similar
strategy of smoothing out the conversion
now saw witness of course a festival
that is now strongly associated with a
modern holiday of Halloween and in fact
both saw when and also as in Saints Day
and there's sort of syncretism whereas
synthesis is what makes up a lot of what
we associate with Halloween today and I
cover this in a previous video in my
shock Tauber series which you can find
on the channel now the second aspect of
this location that is a very interesting
as of course the old churches themselves
the two older churches one from the 12th
century and the other from the 17th can
still be seen today at least partially
one has found the foundations of these
old buildings so that one can see their
science and general form still today the
12th century church might be one of the
oldest in the entire region of Sweden
and thus is a memory of a time when
Christianity was relatively new here now
this is what I love about studying
history and religion as one can often
imagine what it must have been like for
the people living here and wonder over
what their experience of religion was
the church was placed right next to the
lake and one can picture how people from
different parts of this larger community
arrived perhaps my boats and walked up
these stone steps to the church and what
did the service look like how many
people visited regularly this is 800
years ago and it's almost impossible to
imagine what the world would have
appeared like to them but it is really
exciting to think about and wonder this
is just one church in a small community
and yet it contains so much history so
many people have been here so much has
happened and there's a chumma most every
other place like this it gives us a look
into
the past and a relatively early
Christian community but it also tells us
very interesting things about the very
spread of the religion and how the
transition from pre-christian to
Christian times worked so the next time
you drive by is something like a church
on or building remember that it probably
has a lot of interesting things to tell
you I'll see you next time
[Music]